alors le coup de coeur du ciné cette
semaine c'est évidemment les éditions du
festival 51 dédié au documentaire avec
pour thématique cette année la musique
donc plusieurs événements ciné set je
vais très vite le vendredi 10 sept
le public pourra voir gratuitement un
très beau documentaire ce qu'ils
savaient ce qu'il faut de silence sur la
jeunesse d'un concerto le samedi 18
soirées spéciales j'assiste à 18h30 sur
youssef le gant brille c'est l'histoire
de youssef qui a fabriqué lui même ses
instruments de musique qui sera dans la
salle et qui viendra organisé un petit
concert mini concert et le 18 à 10
heures 30 une séance pour les enfants
six courts métrages et la clôture à
partir de 16h où nous diffuserons le
documentaire sur pierre barou et on
assistera à la remise des prix du
festival
et n'oubliez pas de venir découvrir sur
nos écrans cette semaine le très beau
film d'albert dupontel
au revoir la --et du très bon roman de
pierre lemaitre un film exceptionnel les
gens sortent ravis c'est une très belle
adaptation très réussie pour une fois
d'un très grand nombre
un dingue qui lui masquait qui dessine à
longueur de journée tu vends des
monuments aux morts vivants
[Musique]